[Musica]
hanno 1938 adolf hilter sequel adolf
hitler viene in visita proprio qui a
napoli arrivano sui marciapiedi tutti i
napoletani il popolo si riversa e
aspetta il fiore che sfili la tensione è
palpabile
un sentimento misto fra imbarazzo paura
e curiosità si fa avanti il fuhrer
saluta tutti quanti dalla sua auto
scoperta con il classico saluto nazista
braccio e mano tesa a un certo punto tra
il pubblico
una voce anonima si fa avanti rompe il
silenzio e pronuncia le seguenti parole
sta verezzi fora chiove che tradotto
dall'antico latino significa sta
controllando se piove
ebbene una battuta ingenua che realtà in
quel momento storico aveva un potere
enorme
un salto un salto dal contesto un salto
in alto uno jump appunto che aveva
sancito che il totalitarismo non avrebbe
mai e poi mai conquistato il cuore dei
napoletani
ebbene questo è la forza dell'umorismo
che riesce a prendere un nemico pauroso
e lo trasforma in un personaggio piccolo
piccolo e quella torta in faccia
scagliata verso il volto di un nobile
che per citare totò lo va a livellare lo
mette sulla stessa linea del resto del
genere umano e quella buccia di banana
che fa scivolare una donna troppo
imbellettata un uomo arrogante
e lo fa cadere per terra nel fango e
quella storiella idis che con ironia
spiega un po di più della complessità
del mondo
ebbene io questa cosa l'avevo intuito
l'avevo capito sin da piccolo non per
fortuna sulla mia pelle ma non ho mai
dico mai sottovalutato il potere
dell'umorismo
mi ha aiutato tantissime volte mi ha
aiutato a farmi accettare ad avere nuove
amicizie ad avere fidanzate a sposare la
donna che amo mi ha aiutato tantissimo
nel mio lavoro da pubblicitario e in
quanto ateo mi ha dato anche un senso
alla vita che un senso non ce l'ha
ho quindi iniziato a studiare
l'umorismo sotto la lente della
psicologia della sociologia
ho studiato i suoi meccanismi
la sua matematica i suoi stilemi o
persino studiato la gelotologia però non
ho mai pensato che l'umorismo potesse
essere anche negativo
una risata vi seppellirà un giorno senza
riso una giornata perduta dicevano del
resto l'umorismo ti fa stare bene ti fa
volere bene ti rende sereno che regala
momenti di intra scura bile felicità è
fisiologicamente ti da anche delle
endorfine che sono parenti dell'occhio e
chi dar che ti creano euforia e che
inibiscono il dolore che poi il momento
motivo per cui a volte tra le corsie
degli ospedali si può scorgere qualche
clown che si trovano anche fra i
corridoi del parlamento però questa è
un'altra storia e io ho sempre a priori
difeso l'umorismo charlie hebdo black
black humour qualsiasi battuta
meno felice tutto questo in memoria
della libertà di espressione
però poi un giorno non tanto distante da
questo mi sono guardato allo specchio mi
sono riflesso
ho riflettuto e mi sono fatto una
domanda possono essere per assurdo si
intende essere più affascinante di
quello che sono ha risposto ovviamente
no allora mi sono fatto una domanda un
pochino più profonda può l'umorismo
essere strumentalizzato con uno scopo
negativo ovvero paul umorismo
deliberatamente fare del male allora ho
iniziato ad analizzare il lato oscuro
dell'umorismo
partendo dai rapporti interpersonali
passando poi attraverso il concetto di
normalità nella nostra società
allargando il campo alla comunicazione
di massa digitale tramite social e
atterrando poi al significato della
satira politica odierna
allora partiamo dai rapporti
interpersonali quelli più intimi
parliamo quindi di bullismo e per
bullismo non intendo la violenza fisica
che se volete quella più onesta perché
visibile e nemmeno la violenza verbale
le parolacce che sono anonime banali non
sono ad personam
io parlo della violenza psicologica
tramite la derisione dove un gruppo di
individui un branco o anche un individuo
singolo sceglie di attaccare un elemento
debole
oppure semplicemente perché diverso e
questo lo fa sia per mettono in
imbarazzo ma per sembrare una persona
arguta intelligente simpatica e
conquistare il resto del gruppo insomma
un vero e proprio concorso alla battuta
più divertente che per carità nella
forma fa ridere se conoscete anche il
target è il contesto e viene spesso
usata sui sui social perché nascosti
dietro un monitor
se anche il tempo di essere creativi di
fare brainstorming e cercare la battuta
più divertente che possa avere
più like però questo ovviamente crea dei
danni psicologici nella vittima lo va a
ghettizzare la vittima si auto isola che
se ci pensate bene è la stessa cosa che
accadde a una dimensione più allargata
con le barzellette intendo ovviamente le
barzellette politicamente scorrette che
se la prendono con determinato gruppo
sociale che sembrano essere innocenti ma
realtà sono pericolosissime per
intenderci in una società come quella
italiana per esempio si forma una
cultura che ti dice cosa è giusto e cosa
è sbagliato
si crea quindi la specie di perimetro al
cui interno c'è la normalità nel momento
in cui nasce un filone umoristico quel
gruppo sociale viene culturalmente
defenestrato dal perimetro di normalità
e quindi nascono le barzellette sugli
omosessuali nascono le barzellette che
se la prendono con chi al colore diverso
dalla della pelle sulle donne sulla su
un culto religioso in particolare sui
vegani oddio magari sui vegani hanno
anche ragione però fondamentalmente che
cosa succede si crea una sorta di monito
per cui se tu vuoi essere un cittadino
rispettabile se vuoi essere parte della
normalità non devi essere oggetto di
derisione e quindi magari l'omosessuale
nasconde la sua reale è normale natura
oppure che al colore della pelle diverso
in comincia ad avere paura perché oltre
a essere oggetto di derisione il
passaggio alla violenza verbale alla
violenza fisica è molto breve e se
vogliamo a ingrandire la nostra ricerca
sulla comunicazione di massa tramite
il digital e social c'è un fenomeno
fenomeno tener presente gli altri aids
l'alternativa wright che la destra
alternativa americana che si è
sviluppata negli ultimi anni che
accomunata più che altro da quello che
odia più e da quello che ama ed è un
coacervo di tendenzialmente maschi che
sono maschilisti misogini maschi beta
nazionalisti e xenofobi islamofobici e
pare addirittura qualcuno sia juventino
e che cosa fanno
[Musica]
che cosa fanno queste persone si
incontrano online e discutono oltre alla
loro ideologia hanno anche un
particolare modo di scherzare che sono i
meme politicamente scorretti che per
questo motivo secondo il viral marketing
di 21 virali e in un mondo dove non ci
si informa più tramite i quotidiani non
si legge si leggono sempre meno libri e
ci si informa più sul digital sul social
pare e dico pare che questi memories tc
più le fake news abbiano contribuito in
maniera importante alle ultime elezioni
americane fenomeno dell'art wright che è
arrivato anche in europa è arrivato in
francia in germania e in italia ci sono
i primi germi che siano consapevoli o
involontari e l'italia come altre
nazioni democratiche
pare che abbia perso il significato
originario della satira politica
il significato che nasceva da
giambattista che era un commediografo e
poeta latinista francese che aveva
coniato i tempi la locuzione castigat
ridendo mores ovvero che la fatina stati
la politica è in grado di correggere i
costumi tramite il riso
e perché l'italia non lo ha un po perso
questo questo concetto
ve lo spiego meglio esistono nella
nostra società delle regole e delle
convenzioni sociali e culturali che
tutti noi pedissequamente seguiamo che
ci può essere però un individuo che
devia cioè viola una regola questo caso
magari un personaggio politico e quando
arriva la satira tramite una barzelletta
una battuta una vignetta suscita nel
popolo il riso è a sua volta dovrebbe
portare al personaggio deviato
umiliazione e imbarazzo vergogna ed
emarginazione questo punto il
personaggio degli ato potrebbe aver
capito di sbagliare e quindi tornare
sulla retta via
oppure per quieto vivere fa finta e
comunque ritorna sul sul binario oppure
potrebbe invece reiterare continuare nel
suo errore
la sua violazione e a questo punto è una
situazione di stallo perché magari la
satira continua nei suoi confronti
però quel personaggio può diventare
addirittura simpatico al popolo perché
umano nel suo errare e arriviamo un
momento di accettazione perché la verità
è che la satira è vero che può farti
pensare ma non è detto che ti faccia
agire allora forse sarebbe più giusto
che la satira andasse a fustigare il
popolo che andasse in realtà a prendere
quelli italiano medio che poi è lui che
decide nelle urne di votare quel
politico perché la sua realizzazione del
potere soprattutto perché lo vede vede
corrotto vede quello che fa e non c'è la
certezza della pena
quindi l'umorismo è un'arma è un'arma
potentissima e in quanto arma può fare
del bene come può fare del male
dobbiamo tutti fare attenzione a quello
per cui ridiamo perché un attimo passare
dal riso al riso ignorante al riso amaro
harris oscuro non possiamo nemmeno
accettare la censura e nemmeno seguire
quella quell'essere politicamente
estremamente corretti perché poi alla
fine andiamo a negare la nostra
creatività e la nostra libertà di
pensiero di espressione
dovremo fare un'altra cosa dovremmo
invece allenare tutti gli strumenti che
ci fanno capire il perché ridiamo ci
fanno capire il contesto dovremmo
allenare quella che io chiamo la
coscienza comica che tramite
l'educazione la cultura
l'apertura di pensiero la consapevolezza
del momento in cui viviamo ci può
permettere di ridere ancora di tutto
e per questo non essere quegli stolti
nella cui bocca abbonda il riso ma
possiamo essere quelle persone
acculturate quelle persone illuminate
capaci di fare quel salto quel salto che
ci fa vedere la storia da un altro punto
di vista e ci fa vedere il mondo per
quello che è una grandissima mozzarella
di bufala
grazie
[Applauso]